this right here is a map of the persian
empire in 490 bce before the common era
and you see that is an extensive empire
it was established by cyrus the great
and then his successors we talked about
it in previous videos how they were able
to conquer the neo-babylonian empire in
539 bce and then go on to conquer much
of the middle east
able to conquer the long-lived egyptian
empire and they seem somewhat
unstoppable at this point in 490 bce at
this point we have darius is ruler of
the persian empire the achaemenid empire
as it's often referred to
and they're able to keep expanding
until they come across some
unexpected unexpectedly resistant people
and that's the greeks and this is
probably one of the most famous and
legendary stories in history the rivalry
the conflicts between the persians and
the greeks and you should maybe take it
with a little bit of grain of salt
because what we know of it the history
that i'm about to give you comes to us
from herodotus and herodotus who's often
known as the father of history he was
greek and he also lived after a lot of
these conflicts happened and he wrote
about these conflicts his adult life was
well after these happened so he had to
talk to people who are around that time
and obviously he is getting the greek
side of the story there are no surviving
persian accounts for it so you might
want to take it with a grain of salt
because the accounts of herodotus do
tend to make the greeks look pretty good
but let's just talk about what happened
because
taking it with a grain of salt it is a
fascinating series of stories
so you have darius king you can see the
extent of the persian empire in 490 bc
or really at the turn of the century if
we were to go back 10 years to 500 bce
but they are in control of some folks
who
are are a little bit more rebellious
than most of the people that are within
the persian empire and they are in this
region right over here known as ionia
where you had greek settlements that are
now under persian control and from 500
bce to about 494 bce so kind of that the
first 10 years of the fifth centu the
fifth century bce you have a serious a
series of revolts in ionia and let me
zoom in on that a little bit so we can
see that
you can see our timeline
right over here
so this area we're now zoomed in this
area is referred to as ionia this would
be modern day the coast of modern day
turkey we are out here on the anatole
anatolian peninsula
and these rebellions in 498 bce the
rebels are able to take over and burn
down sardis which is under persian
control the persians under darius are
not happy about this so they send a
force to
to
to take back control and also to get a
little bit of revenge because when the
rebels were able to take over sardis
they had help from some of their greek
brethren and it's important to note that
the greeks weren't some type of a
unified state they weren't a unified
empire like the persians were they were
a fragmented group of city-states you
have the famous athens corinth sparta
all of these city-states they shared a
common language they shared similar
religion but they were not one unified
empire but when their brethren the the
the greek rebels these these ionic
rebels i guess you could say
rose up against the their persian rulers
they had assistance from
athenians
and from folks in eritrea
and so when darius finds out about this
not only does he want to take back what
the rebels had he wants to suppress them
he wants to he wants to put down that
rebellion he also wants to have revenge
on the athenians and the eritreans and
so the first thing he does is he sends
out a fleet in 492 bce
so you see his fleet here in green
this fleet that i am tracing
he sends it out in order to
in order to in order to seek revenge on
the athenians in the eritreans but he is
unlucky and once again these are the
accounts of herodotus his fleet his
large fleet runs into a storm and is
mostly destroyed and is mostly destroyed
and so in 492 bce the persians are
unsuccessful
but they are not satisfied darius is not
happy with that idea that we are the
largest uh empire known we should be
able to take on these fragmented greeks
with a much smaller population much less
wealth than the mighty persians do so in
490 bce he sends out another attempt to
take over
to seek revenge and to subjugate the
eritreans and the athenians and this
time he is a little bit more successful
his fleet is not destroyed so this is in
this brown color i'll try to color it in
this brown color right over here you can
see the path of the fleet this time and
he is eventually he is able to subjugate
and take over eritrea but as he's going
to
athens which you can see right here they
decide to stop at marathon they just
that that word might be familiar to you
and we'll talk about it in a second why
it is and that is where they are engaged
by the athenians and the athenians are
able to put are able to defeat the
persians and this is a very big deal in
history once again this is herodotus's
account but up to that point the
persians seemed invincible but now the
athenians were able to actually
destroy them in a battle and the persian
fleet they go back to their boats they
run back to their boats according to
herodotus and many of them are killed as
they as they retreat and they're going
to go back around the peninsula
potentially to go attack athens but they
decide not to and they retreat
now the word marriage so this is a very
big deal in history first of all is that
uh this mighty empire is put back in
this battle it often times
historians will mark it as the beginning
of uh kind of greek ascendancy group the
ascendancy of greek civilization at the
end of these greco-persian wars and
we're really just in the beginning
periods of right now that's really the
beginning of the greek golden age but as
we'll see these war the greco-persian
wars are not over with the battle at
marathon that was just the first i guess
major interaction over the next few
decades now one thing that you might be
saying is hey that word marathon that
seems familiar
maybe some of you have run a marathon or
you want to run a marathon going 26.2
miles you might say is there any
relation to this to this battle to this
location on in greece called marathon
and the simple answer is yes so there is
an apocryphal story when people say
pocketful they're like well we're not
sure if it really happened or maybe
didn't happen and this one people are
pretty sure it didn't happen the story
goes something like when they had the
battle a messenger was sent from
marathon to athens and the distance from
marathon to athens is roughly the
distance of a modern marathon around 25
or 26 miles and the apocryphal story
goes they went to deliver the message of
the persian attack and the success of
the athenians and then when the
messenger gave that message he just
passed out and died and so when the
modern olympics that that we've set up
now over the last 100 and something
years they said hey let's have an event
that celebrates that run from marathon
to athens and that's where our modern
marathon actually comes from now the
actual story as best as i can figure out
and i encourage you to look up primary
documents to figure this out for
yourself is it's mixing up a few stories
after the victory at marathon the
athenian the athenian army did quickly
mobilize and go back to athens and cover
that distance in order to defend athens
because remember it looks like the
persian fleet were coming around were
coming around this peninsula right over
here to get to athens the story of that
runner is there was a runner named
philippines who was sent from athens to
sparta to convey a message that's
actually a much further distance in a
lot ways it's much more impressive but
those two stories were mixed up together
into the story of marathon which is
where we get our modern day distance of
the marathon hey let's all run roughly
the distance from marathon to athens in
the next video we'll see that the
persians are not done
darius will not be able to seek the
revenge that he wants in his lifetime
but his son xerxes is going to keep
going at it